when i completely agree with you that
it's a disgrace this announcement of
this importance was not first made to
parliament and i look forward to the
leak inquiry that you uh mentioned as
well
may i take this opportunity to
congratulate the secretary of state for
coming top of the teacher's pet list she
was the first cabinet minister to tweet
support for the prime minister she was
the first to volunteer
to do a broadcast round and now she's
been the first to throw up a distraction
and in finding someone else to blame for
the prime minister's disintegrating
leadership
the bbc is reporting of course
the license fee deal must be fair to fee
payers whilst ensuring the bbc can do
what it does best there should be no
blank checks
however the government claims this is
all about the cost of living crisis i
mean pull the other one
what is it about the 13 pounds 57p a
month that marks it out for such
immediate and special attention to
address the cost of living
over the 1200 pounds a year increase
in energy and household bills
or the 3 000 pounds a year taxes
increases that her government has
imposed
is the license fee really at the heart
of the cost of living crisis
or is this really about their
long-standing vendetta against the bbc
now it's part of operation red meat to
save the prime minister from becoming
dead meat
apparently negotiations with the bbc
hadn't even been finalized when the
culture secretary gave the details to
the sunday newspaper on the very weekend
the prime minister's position was most
imperil
i leave it to you and others mr speaker
to judge the timing of that
she has proven today the conservatives
may know the price of the license fee
but not its value
the last time they targeted it the over
75s paid the price
so what assessment has she made of the
impact of this two-year freeze on bbc
output and commissioning and on the
wider creative industries more broadly
is she happy to become the secretary of
state for repeats
but this isn't enough
oh there's more coming there's more
coming we've got lots of fun to be had
with this don't worry
but this isn't enough red meat for the
culture secretary she won't stop until
her cultural vandalism has destroyed
everything that's great about britain
vandalism is exactly what it is to tweet
on a sunday with no notice no discussion
or thought the end to the unique funding
of the bbc altogether without any clue
as to what will replace it
so perhaps she will explain how the bbc
will continue valued services that just
wouldn't be commercially viable
first how can it continue to support
local journalism where so many have
recently failed in many areas the bbc is
the last local newsdesk standing yeah
second
how would a commercial only bbc be able
to play such a crucial role as it has
done to leveling up and growing the
creative industries across our regions
and nations from cardiff to salford and
elsewhere
the silent on that one
i support the increased funding for s4c
but they claim to support the union so
what assurance can she provide for the
continuation of distinct broadcasting in
wales scotland and northern ireland when
there's no licence fee
third would her cutback bbc be able to
continue with the world service and its
global soft power which this which her
government's review only last year
described as the most trusted
broadcaster worldwide would it
finally what would happen to bbc
learning bite size and children's
educational programming which frankly
did a much better job than the
government did of getting high quality
education into children's home during
lockdown when they couldn't even provide
an ipad
the impartiality of the bbc is crucial
to trust in it
by explicitly linking the charter
renewal to the bbc's editor
quite rightly i wanted to the secretary
of state in silence i expect the same
respect to be given to the shadow
secretary and those voices that i keep
hearing
i know who's behind the mask so let me
reassure you
that if you want to go out early don't
let me help you on your way lucy paul
i actually know that the honourable
member is a big fan of mine but he's
just trying to hide it behind his mask
the impartiality of the bbc is crucial
to trust in it by explicitly linking the
charter renewal to the bbc's editorial
decisions the government sounds more
like a tin pot dictatorship than a
healthy democracy the bbc creates great
quality british produce programming from
royal weddings to strictly come dancing
to great british drama and championing
of new music it's at the cutting edge of
harnessing the digital age
of course it needs to change with the
times and review its output and reach
but it is a well-loved trusted
british treasure it is the envy of the
world
but the government is in trouble mr
speaker the prime minister is casting
around for people to blame and the
culture secretary has stepped up to
provide some red meat well it won't work
this is not how the future of our jewel
in the crown and the cornerstone of our
world-leading creative industries should
be determined she will have a fight on
her hands if she wants to destroy